Nicholas is there a camera or piece of
equipment that you're very excited you
cannot wait what comes out okay I don't
think there's anything like really knew
that has been Malaysia I'm really
looking forward to work with the black
magic and the c300 you know art like the
next natural step and we shot the film
with five days on one lease and it was
the most amazing amazing thing we ever
decided to do because you know the film
looks amazing it was freely really easy
to shoot with them and I think these
cameras are the like the next step so
I'm really looking forward to try them
I'm really excited to I'm looking
forward to use them and i hope this that
they are a CCA assist ease as the 5d
wars on a school good looking
you